l'offre l'enveloppent surprise non
thierry carteron fromager howell de
tours est un habitué du concours général
agricole des fromages il vient ici
depuis dix huit ans comme juré la
première chose que j'ai fait ce matin
courir c'est de voir des producteurs
permis sur certains produits que je
recherche
comme j'ai cherché à à brebis fermiers
du béarn là je cherchais justement un
autre master pour voir si je peux
trouver un autre master de printemps a
changé et varié mes produits en
conséquence un millier de jurés sont
réunis dans cette salle les
professionnels des produits laitiers
mais aussi des consommateurs je suis né
dans le berry et je connais tous ceux du
prix ni saint-pierre du 5 sur cher du va
lancer cinq morts tous ses fromages
je les connais bien aussi bien dans ses
dents pour une pâte comme ça dure ou
heures de fromage frais et j'apprécie
beaucoup de fromages de chèvre
fromage pour général mais au fromage de
chève tout particulièrement
chaque groupe doit évaluer plusieurs
échantillons de fromage les critères la
forme l'aspect la texture d'odeur et
look
ils vont attribuer une note de 1 à 20
sur chacun de ces critères et le
président de jury va ensuite collecter
l'ensemble des notes et faire la moyenne
pour évaluer la la qualité finale de
chacun des produits est attribué ou non
une médaille d'or d'argent de bronze
c'est le produit de mérite vraiment
après les meilleurs fromages de france
les vins du loir et cher étaient à la
fête dans le pavillon des produits de la
région centre isabelle deux fronts cours
est venu apprendre à déguster ces
appellations telles que cheverny
touraine wali et twente fait aujourd'hui
ce qu'on ressent en fin de bouche ce
sont les arômes que vous avez déjà perçu
au nez alors qu'ils peuvent évoluer
parce que le vin évolue dans le temps
puis il est aérée plus est dévolu sur
des arômes complexes
moi je vais de la côte d'azur la france
est à l'habitude de boire du rosé c'est
n'a rien à voir donc c'est très agréable
de découvrir et elle produit les
fictions vance c'est moche hcb rosée sur
une côte de provence en plus de tanins
en plus de son fruité
celui ci est plus pire us minéral c'est
que les gens puissent découvrir le vent
d'une façon
j'irai ludique qu'on puisse leur
apporter les quelques explications qui
peuvent leur permettre justement dans
les dégustations pouvoir après tester
eux-mêmes avec ces trois notions
importantes que sont la vue le nez et la
bouche en fait en quelques minutes ses
visiteurs ont découvert des 20 qu'il ne
connaissait pas du tout tout en
apprenant à les déguster découvrir
s'enivrer c'est bien pour ça que les
producteurs viennent présenter leurs
produits au salon